[Música]
un centro comercial en el estado de
Texas fue el escenario del más reciente
tiroteo en Estados Unidos la policía de
la comunidad de Allen señaló que al
menos nueve personas murieron en el
ataque
los nueve países de América que hacen
parte de la como West también vivieron
la coronación del Rey Carlos tercero de
Reino Unido pero de distintas maneras
mientras en Canadá festejaron en islas
del Caribe reivindicaron sus deseos de
separarse de la monarquía británica
los chilenos van a las urnas para
decidir quién redactará el segundo
borrador de la nueva constitución en las
elecciones del domingo deberán elegir a
las 50 personas de la convención
constitucional
Bienvenidos a las noticias que France 24
dedica a América yo soy María Clara
calle
empezamos en Estados Unidos donde el más
reciente de tiroteo ocurrió en un centro
comercial en la comunidad de Allen a
unos 40 kilómetros de Dallas Texas las
autoridades dicen que un hombre se bajó
de su coche y comenzó a disparar mató a
al menos nueve personas e hirió a otras
siete de acuerdo con las declaraciones
de la policía de Allen luego las
autoridades mataron al tirador la red de
hospitales de la ciudad agregó que los
heridos que atendieron tienen entre 5 y
61 años Esto fue lo que dijo la policía
sobre el ataque
a las 3:36 nuestro oficial recibió una
llamada y escuchó sonidos de disparos
localizó al tirador por el sonido de los
disparos
neutralizó al tirador y neutralizó la
amenaza pensamos en este punto que el
tirador actuó solo pedimos a la
comunidad su ayuda
Esto es una investigación en desarrollo
tenemos un fuerte apoyo del Condado y
del Estado el sábado fue la coronación
del Rey Carlos III aunque las miradas se
enfocaron en Londres el cambio de la
monarquía también impacta a otros 14
países del mundo que hacen parte de la
como Wells 9 de ellos están ubicados en
América a continuación lluís Muñoz nos
trae las celebraciones que hubo en
Canadá y las reivindicaciones de Jamaica
Reino Unido y otros 14 países de la
common West celebraron la coronación de
su Rey Carlos III por ejemplo este
sábado se convirtió en monarca de Canadá
el segundo país en importancia en Ottawa
a la capital las autoridades del país
también vivieron una ceremonia especial
desde nuestros comienzos como Colonia
francesa hasta hoy la monarquía ha sido
una parte integral de nuestras
instituciones y nuestra identidad
la sangre de nuestros corazones Envía un
canto de esperanza en reconocimiento a
Carlos III El rey de la commonwell
Carlos III es rey en nueve países de
América excepto Canadá y Belice el resto
son islas del Caribe donde hay un
movimiento republicano creciente el
último en cambiar de forma de estado fue
Barbados Jamaica aspira a ser el
siguiente allí la celebración fue vista
con apatía y también de forma
reivindicativa
todavía tenemos instituciones de la
esclavitud y la colonización con
nosotros hoy en 2023 y necesitamos hacer
mucho más por lo que esta eliminación
del Rey termina simbólicamente con esa
fase de nuestro viaje
Isabel II nunca dejó de mirar a América
de hecho su primer viaje internacional
en 1953 fue a Panamá 70 años después
Carlos III tendrá dos retos cultivar los
lazos con América y sobre todo mantener
la corona en los países donde este
sábado comienza a reinar
y varios líderes del mundo asistieron a
esta coronación uno de ellos fue el
presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva El mandatario afirmó que tuvo
la oportunidad de hablar con el Rey
Carlos III y que este le hizo una
petición muy concreta para defender el
medio ambiente Esto fue lo que dijo Lula
lo primero que me dijo el rey fue que
tenía que cuidar la amazonía y le
respondí
Necesito ayuda no es solo de nuestra
voluntad Necesito ayuda y mucho recursos
vamos a cumplir la promesa que hicimos
de acabar con la deforestación para el
eso es casi una cuestión de honor
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
se retractó y reconoció que el fiscal
general de la nación no está bajo su
subordinación luego de que el mismo
mandatario afirmara que él era el jefe
del fiscal
Gustavo Petro se retracta y baja la
temperatura en su enfrentamiento con la
fiscalía el presidente de Colombia lo
hizo desde Portugal en plena gira
ibérica y tras un llamado de atención de
la Corte Suprema con las drogas acepto
el llamado de la honorable Corte Suprema
de Justicia respeto y respetaré la
autonomía independencia de la fiscalía
general de la nación y todas las ramas
del poder público pero como presidente
de la república no guardaré silencio
frente a estas gravísimas denuncias el
viernes Petro había dicho ser el jefe
del fiscal Francisco Barbosa esto le
causó reprimendas públicas de distintos
sectores criticado por no entender la
separación de poderes el fiscal Barbosa
escogido por el expresidente Iván Duque
fue más allá dijo que sacar a su familia
del país y realizó la siguiente
acusación Petro se cambió el traje de
demócrata y se empieza a poner un traje
de dictador
Petro y Barbosa se han estado
enfrentando durante meses por los planes
de paz total del presidente la escalada
final llegó esta semana después de que
Petro invocando a la Constitución
pidiera información a la fiscalía lo
hizo En referencia a una investigación
periodística de la nueva prensa y el
periodista Gonzalo guillem afirmaba que
el fiscal delegado de Barbosa Daniel
Hernández habría recibido información
previa de 200 asesinatos que iban a ser
cometidos por el plan del Golfo el
fiscal habría ignorado las alertas las
muertes habrían ocurrido y habría
protegido a los asesinos
chile irá este domingo a las urnas para
elegir a los miembros del Consejo
constitucional las 50 personas que sean
elegidas deberán redactar una segunda
propuesta de constitución política luego
de que en septiembre del 2022 los
ciudadanos rechazarán a través de un
referendo el primer borrador de la Carta
Magna
en un segundo intento por cambiar su
Constitución el gobierno de izquierda de
Gabriel Boris ha llamado a elecciones
para elegir a los integrantes del
Consejo constitucional el cual deberá
redactar un nuevo texto de la Carta
Magna después del fracaso de septiembre
del año pasado cuando un 62% de los
chilenos rechazó mediante un plebiscito
el primer borrador constitucional
Obviamente que también hay un consenso
dentro de los chilenos de una nueva
constitución y ese consenso mayoritario
es lo que nos tiene en este segundo
proceso constitucional Y tratar de
escribir Ahora sí una buena alternativa
puede ser algo que está claro y que
aprendimos con el rechazo anterior es
que nadie se cambia algo peor los
críticos han dicho que el primer texto
era demasiado largo y con poca Claridad
ahora 15 millones de chilenos están
llamados a elegir 50 candidatos entre
una lista de 350 en la lección de este
siete de mayo Esperamos que Maya de que
el voto es obligatorio y todos tienen
que concurrir a las urnas a votar se
entienda la importancia importancia de
votar informadamente no se eligen a los
consejeros y consejeras constitucionales
que van a deliberar sobre la propuesta
de un nuevo texto constitucional para
Chile luego de la elección de los
delegados se espera que se conforme
oficialmente el consejo para que empiece
a trabajar en el nuevo texto para
posteriormente presentarlo a los
chilenos y que se ha votado para su
aprobación o rechazo en diciembre la
catedral de San Juan el divino en la
ciudad de Nueva York celebró una inusual
misa los feligreses son ciclistas
ataviados con cascos y ropa deportiva
llevan sus bicicletas para que el
párroco las bendiga el acto simbólico y
reivindicativo también Busca visibilizar
las muertes de los ciclistas en las
calles neoyorquinas marinas sardina
tiene la historia
hasta el altar en bicicleta pero no
suenan campanas de boda sino de protesta
decenas de ciclistas acuden a la cita
anual de bendición de las bicicletas en
la catedral de San Juan el divino en
Nueva York creo que es una verdadera
parodia que sea tan peligroso ser
ciclista en la ciudad de Nueva York
especialmente desde la pandemia Parece
que la gente conduce de forma más
agresiva más rápido distraídos y todo
eso pone en riesgo la vida de los
ciclistas lo que nos mantendrá a salvo
son las infraestructuras como el carril
bici un decano de la Catedral
oficialista esta singular ceremonia que
cumple 25 años en honor a los ciclistas
que perdieron la vida en accidentes de
tránsito al menos 10 en lo que va de año
en pie y con las bicis estacionadas el
párroco rocía agua bendita sobre las
ruedas de los caballitos de acero para
proteger a sus dueños tal vez no me
siento más protegida pero cuidada y es
bueno saber que hay un montón de gente
por ahí en bicicleta que quiere ir
seguro y se preocupan por cómo se
Ejecutan las calles según estudios un
ciclista de Nueva York tiene 25 veces
más probabilidades de morir que un
ciclista de Vancouver o las mismas que
un ciclista en Argentina estas
bendiciones simbólicas no buscan salvar
vidas pero sí visibilizar esta
problemática hasta aquí las noticias
sigan con France 24
[Música]